- [Gary] It's unbelievable how
much I don't care one way
or the one way or the other.
Meaning I don't care
about political correctness.
I'm willing to have
people make fun of me.
But at the same token it's
insane to think in 2017 where EQ
and the market to be human and
not realize that anybody can do
it as long as
they've got the skill
is the great flaw
of that person.
- [Woman] And one of the videos
where I got introduced to you
was you're out of college.
- Yes, yes.
- [Woman] I'm very recently out
of college and this is
my next five years.
So if someone after watching
that video come back to you and
be like okay here I am Gary.
Working for your company--
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Woman] what is the best
advice that you could give me to
make my next five years?
- The number one thing you
should do is have a relationship
with all 700 people here.
I know that there are 316 people
here that disproportionately
affect the outcome of your life
professionally and personally.
And I think you need
to figure that out.
You have it really lucky.
You work in a company where
we've created a culture where
that's appropriate.
99% of these fucking buildings
are filled with companies that
you can't go and say
hello to somebody.
You can do it to me
all the way down.
- [Woman] I'm sitting
here with Gary.
- Exactly.
And what you don't know is this
is not a check the box you could
email me tomorrow be like,
"Hey can we talk for 10
minutes," and it gets done.
And so if I'm doing
that they'll all do that.
I would highly recommend to
push yourself to create
those relationships.
And this new office allows that.
Sitting in the cafeteria for an
hour and just kind of working
but kind of wanting to use it
to say hello, super appropriate.
Super the best use of your time.
- [Woman] All right.
- Awesome.
- [Woman] Thank you.
- Such a pleasure.
- [Woman] Nice to meet you.
- Have a great day.
- [Woman] You too.
(electronic music)
- Hey.
Good to see again.
- Good to see again.
- Hey sir. Vlad.
- Vlad, how are you?
When you come from fucking
shit you have a tough time
calibrating when you have.
Right now one of my biggest
flaws is this is more attractive
to me than the fact that I could
go hire seven full-time CTO type
characters, I can afford it
there's no reason not to but you
know us, right, I still want
to fuckin' hack it together.
I still want, you know?
(electronic music)
Save, let's go for like
45 so we can do 30
that stuff and 15 us
or maybe even hour.
- [DRock] How's your day going?
- Great!
Actually, that's a
good, I got a little rant.
Roma, come in here
and be in my rant.
- Sure.
- Don't say anything.
Just be in it.
- Of course.
- Back to that question, DRock.
I actually had a very
interesting thought lately which
is how do you break people's
mentality to default to looking
at the negative
versus the positive.
Fundamentally, at the end of
the day the truest thing is that
whenever I hear anything I just
default, you lost some weight?
- Yeah, yeah.
- You look good, man.
- Thanks, man.
- You're welcome.
Sorry, fundamentally, I just
look at things and I look at the
positive and I think a lot of
people that are losing are just
defaulting into the negative.
It's really that binary.
Grace, it's that binary.
- 100% agree.
- [Gary] Yeah and it just,
and so how do you, how,
and leave in the comm--,
I'm asking for people
in the comments
I don't know if it's
modern medicine and
everyone's like no,
no, no don't take pills.
I don't know if it's
going and seeing somebody.
I'm trying to figure out how
all the executives,
all the business people,
all the entrepreneurs,
all the people in my life,
how do they default from looking
at the negative
versus the positive.
Like Vinny looks
at the positive.
- Every day I do.
- [Gary] Don't you, don't you
think that you basically when
confronted with something
just look at the positive?
That's been my read on you.
- In a realistic way, you have
to know what's really there but
then you have to focus on the
positive part of it because
otherwise what are we doin'?
- Right.
You can't be like, you can't
just be glossing over issues.
- [Vinny] Right, right.
- It can't be all just
rainbows when it's on fire.
- [Vinny] Yeah. When you
know what's really going on.
- [Gary] Realistic positivity.
- Realistic positivity.
- [Phil] Vayner Capital and
what they want to do
next year, probably.
- [Gary] Can you ask them
if they would put that in?
If we put a certain amount?
Okay, so I need to talk to
Brian for five minutes before.
Hey Lil.
- Hi.
- How are you?
- Great to see you.
- [Lil] Nice to see you.
- [Gary] Are you well?
(electronic music)
That you have for
the app and I'll work on
getting you the best app for
the lowest possible price.
All right. See you later.
I want to stack the deck on
anything that performance based
as much as I can so I want
to really set the tone in one
meeting with all of you like
I really want this to work.
I think it takes a lot of
ego and humility
from every direction.
Anytime you want more oomph
to try to vig the
outcome of success,
you know what this is
a good way to put it,
I think I'm gonna be
able to articulate it.
You need to be smart when
something's on the line.
This is exactly the time to
audit yourself and figure out
where you're strong
and where you're not.
Thanks guys.
You know how many times,
you know this, because
your businessman.
The amount of times, somebody's
had the better product and lost
is a million 'cause that's
why marketing matters so much.
So keep going.
But it's never more fun then to
be behind the marketing of the
best product because
if you can figure it out,
it goes but can bat shit.
(hip hop music)
- [Woman 2] Gary Vaynerchuk who
is a thought later, not just a
thought leader in the industry
of global marketing and digital
marketing but physical and
digital and social and platforms
and all things brands but also
has created a really unique and
disruptive agency
called VaynerMedia.
And touches on all these things.
But what's very
interesting about,
in my opinion,
about Gary is that
he's one of those guys that gets
it and has always had his finger
kind of almost above the pulse.
Before it even happens and
then it becomes something.
I thought it would be very
interesting before we start
diving into our company as
we start tackling things like
content and platforms and
getting into the nitty-gritty.
Gonna kind of get
our mind right.
(inaudible) What's going on
and what necessary today.
Without further adieu, I'd like
to introduce Gary Vaynerchuk.
(applause)
- Thanks.
I'm going to sit.
Thanks for having me.
In a world where everybody
who is winning goes bottom-up
instead of top-down.
When you literally tell your
NGO friends or your friends in
architecture or just a
commonsense bright person that
that's what we do in marketing
they do not understand.
It makes zero sense.
But that's what the
whole ecosystem is built in.
I think the first thing
is you have to break it.
So to me breaking it
comes in a lot of ways.
Number one, we have the tell our
brand managers that they need to
get comfortable with the fact
that their leverage of being the
person that makes a judgment
call on that creative
needs to go away.
I thought one of the more
interesting things, at least
I've heard, one of the more
interesting things in fashion is
people blending now
high-end low-end. Right?
Like, Jesus, don't you understand
that's what's happening in
marketing capabilities too?
Why does every video
have to be like super triple,
if you sat here and
look at all the brands
that have gone
from 0 to 50 million
in revenue strictly
in a digital world
not everything is super
shiny and glossy.
And by the way, if you want
Instagram Stories to be super
shiny and glossy you don't have
to record right from there you
can take stills and upload
them it could you could spend
$400,000 on a 10
second video if you want.
You shouldn't.
The reason I win is I don't
give a shit if I don't
get your business.
And so when I punch your CEO or
CFO or creative director in the
face who cares
either they're going
to respond super well
or they're not.
But I can't ask
you guys to do that.
And then the other problem is
your partners that are supposed
be helping you, they make more
margin if you stay the course.
So why would they tell you that?
Cool.
(applause)
Thanks are having me.
I want you to write about things
that you're interested in.
Now, I think there's a really
interesting video that I made
the other day where I was
talking to a young man and
I said look you need to be
thinking about documenting more
than you need to be
thinking about creating.
And so one of the places, Dave,
where people get really get
caught up here is they get too
precious about trying to make
something too great
this, that the other thing.
- [Man] GaryVee!
- [Gary] Hold on, hold
on one second, Dave.
- Gary.
- Yeah?
- I'm a huge follower of you.
I applied a bunch of
times at your company,
I've been dying to meet you.
- Thank you.
- Can I get a selfie with you?
- Sure. Sure.
- How you doin' today?
- I'm well, I'm well.
- GaryVee! What up, baby?
The man right here.
Biggest thought
leader of our generation.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
Take care.
- DRock.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you.
- You're the best.
- [Gary] Thank you man.
This is perfect I can use
that as content for this call.
I'm not sure exactly what that
kid was, what brought him value
but I can tell you it's
different than what brought
other people value.
- [Man 2] I want to
have a beer, man.
- [Gary] Of course, I want
to have a beer with you now.
- [Man 2] So good to see you.
- [Gary] Good to
see you, brother.
- [Man 2] Congrats on
everything, by the way.
- I've taken it
already a step forward.
I wrote a book in 2011
called Thank You Economy.
We have been working
on what you just saw.
We know how to take listening
and make it actionable
in real-time, creative
and amplification.
That's real.
- [Man 2] That's real.
- That's fuckin' real.
And we're doing it at scale.
This is a multimillion
dollar capability,
we know what were doing.
It's cool man.
(light music)
Alright, DRock where we going?
No, I got another meeting.
- [DRock] Four blocks.
- [Gary] Four blocks? Okay.
- I'll see you.
I'm gonna walk this way.
See ya, Gary.
- See ya, see ya.
- [DRock] Have a good night.
- [Alex] Stay hungry, right?
- What's that? Yes.
- [Alex] Can I get a picture?
- [Gary] Yeah, sure man.
- You've helped me so
much with that motto bro.
- [Gary] Thank you bro,
what's your name?
- Alex.
- Gary.
- Got you.
Got you.
Also I got a vlog I don't
know if you want to?
- Yeah, let's say what's up.
- What's goin' on?
This is Gary from stay hungry
your motto dude I swear to God
he's the reason why
I say stay hungry.
He is the man.
- Thank you brother.
GaryVee, what's up everybody?
Hope you're super well.
Stay hungry.
What are you gonna do?
Die with regret that
you didn't go for it?
- Gotta go hard.
- That's fucked up.
Go hard, baby.
- Thank you, bro.
- See ya man.
- Appreciate it.
- [Gary] Take care.
- Thank you.
You know what?
I love when branding gets to a
place where people know
but you don't know exactly.
You know?
It's so interesting.
Yes, that makes sense.
And so I think it goes
to entrepreneurship.
If you're very passionate about
that I'd rather write you a
$500,000 check to start your
thing 'cause the great thing
about that is
nobody can stop you.
The market stops you, you know?
What I worry about anywhere is
somebody along the way above can
stop it and I hate that shit.
That's my answer, it's putting
yourself in the right playing
field in the beginning.
Let me give you this.
Can you get us from some angles?
Then we're done.
- [DRock] For the night?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [DRock] Alright.
(upbeat music)